patience tactique lecture du jeu et
bonne condition physique à
magny-les-hameaux ce week-end certains
ont joué au poker 22 heures d'affilée en
duo ou en solo pour cette année est
vraiment c'est qu'on fait un nom de tape
en fait on fait vraiment toute la nuit
c'est une variante c'est une idée qu'on
a eu comme ça en fait il ya sûrement des
débutants mais beaucoup veulent un peu
plus d'experts quand même et c'est des
clubs caritatif il n'y a pas d'argent en
jeu
donc voilà on joue pour là pour la bonne
humeur autour pour jouer vraiment propre
plaisir pour le plaisir mais aussi pour
le souvenir
le tournoi a été créé il ya quatre ans
en hommage à un joueur décédé
il a rassemblé cette année neuf club
yvelinois on est habitués on habitue et
sur les tournois les tournois longue
distance moi c'est vrai que 24 heures
c'est un but 24 heures c'est un petit
peu spécial mais chacun sait préparer à
sa façon on va dire on a participé est
alors à la sécurité donc on a vu dans
les sacs y avait un peu différente
chaude et dont je fais partie chocolatés
et des boissons énergétiques des choses
comme ça
puis on a des pauses qui permettent
aussi de prouver et qui porte un chapeau
bas bien situé pour une bonne cause donc
c'est aussi ce qu'on défend poker
associatif
c'est la première année en fait partie
je crois que c'est la première année où
il est organisé en 24 heures donc
l'idéal donc on aligne nos joueurs
disposent venus de tout le département
plus de 120 joueurs se sont affrontés
des dons ont aussi été reversés à
diverses associations du territoire